joining us now first more on our top
story we start tonight with our radio
talk show host syndicated host Larry
elder friend let me start with the with
the shutdown and the president the
president has invited the Democrats day
after day to come and negotiate to talk
about what is life and death at the
border and talk about the government
shutdown they never go they don't want
to negotiate well I think the president
acted in the right way today well I
agree and Shawn here's what gets me
about this whole thing Nancy Pelosi of
all people ought to understand the
position that Donald Trump is in he made
a campaign promise not just a campaign
promise but a promise that he believes
makes the country better
similarly 2008 Barack Obama runs one of
his signature promises was health care
reform which eventually became Obamacare
but it was unpopular as he was
prosecuting the case and to the point
where Massachusetts Democrats lost the
so-called Ted Kennedy seat to Scott
Brown they were demoralized Sean they
were crushed Rahm Emmanuel wanted to
pull the whole thing the person that
bucked Obama up that said go go big or
go home was Nancy Pelosi
she said you made a signature a promise
you need to fulfill it and and Donald
Trump made a promise he's trying to do
the same thing to fulfill a campaign
promise that he made that he not also
believes will improve the country's
security I think that country better
it's 90 percent right so coming across
that border into this country that's a
that's exactly right so why would Nancy
Pelosi understand the pressure that
Obama was under and encouraged him to
pursue Obamacare but expect Donald Trump
to completely dropkick a plan a promise
that he made repeatedly to his base it
doesn't even make any political sense
she understands that Larry
they've got we're talking about
literally they all took their vacations
for Christmas they didn't stay and
negotiate for the furloughed employees
ten days in then you got other Democrats
taking of lobbyists paid junket to a
luxurious resort in Puerto Rico looks
like they were having fun then you got
Nancy going away and in that seven-day
period that means those 800,000
furloughed employees would not get
another check she seemingly doesn't care
about the moles she claims to care but
we got life and death
let me ask you this we've got these new
radicals in the Democratic Party
outspoken anti-semites associations with
the women's March and those people that
support Farrakhan I don't hear any
criticism amongst the Democratic
leadership about any of this now and you
won't and it gets even worse Don al
Sharpton who's a friend and associate of
Farrakhan is being visited by many of
these prospective presidential
candidates the Bloomberg Cory Booker
Elizabeth Warren Gillian bran have all
met with him or planned on meeting with
him he al Sharpton has not renounced his
friendship with Farrakhan has now is not
renounced the anti-semitic comments that
you've just now played by the way you
mentioned Steny Hoyer the House Majority
Leader he also said that walls sometimes
even work so not only has he broken away
from Nancy Pelosi a little bit here he
is acknowledging that walls quote
sometimes work I thought they didn't
work I thought they were inefficient I
thought they were waste of money yeah
and I thought it was a manufactured
crisis why wouldn't Nancy meet with
angel moms and dads she was in her
office they were outside her door you
know why she wouldn't mean what was he
going to say she even said about please
sister but he she said about a police
officer who was killed well we don't
live in a perfect world really whenever
there's a mass shooting the same people
that say we don't live in a perfect
world want to draft more laws to
restrict the Second Amendment in
response well we don't live in a perfect
world but not that satisfy her but
there's a mass shooting but when a
person is killed by an illegal alien hey
stuff happens we don't live in a perfect
world
it's a voracious I got a run Larry thank
you for being with us we'll have a lot
more on this coming up during the show